my home island grows near when we get
there my brothers will bus to in each of
you great knowledge hopefully turn this
season around I don't see anything
before you see them you'll hear them
[Music]
what is that some sort of chant
it's a rant a Van Gundy and Ron Tobias
these monks have taken a vow of no
silence
[Music]
here's a large kid
[Music]
that's lovely akhom wasn't a lot for
minions before getting annoyed oh there
she is
the Isle of Van Gundy home sweet home
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
haha brother Stein brother Joe the hell
are you the whole fat review systems a
mess nobody listens to me how are you
I'm miserable we're stuck in the damn
nine seat and I've tried everything
could use a bit your help brother Jeff
father Van Gundy and monks will always
help a coach you need Knights Detroit
come here in form of a wall I want you
to meet my brothers this is Jeff Van
Gundy
hello their butts Ethan Van Gundy
pleasure to meet you rev Van Gundy that
there's John Van Gundy cretins
I'm their second cousin this little guy
is Gundy Van Gundy he's severely good
indeed so don't say nothing about Lord
Management and firmly Ethan can you show
tonight's thither chambers a training
begins bright and early tomorrow can't
make a free throws they're gonna hack
y'all day I don't know I just sort of
feel like I don't need analytics to tell
me LeBron is good you know I know that I
can see that I'm just not sure I'll be
enough brother Jeff the Lords of Detroit
will have me head if we don't make a run
in the playoffs this year you know there
is another option I mean you are the
master of trades right huh well I hear
whispers of a wealthy Lord is looking to
part ways with his most decorated night
if I send a raven now they could be here
on tomorrow oh hi hi juice a screw it
sander even I think you're gonna like
him brother Stan he's even Balder and
louder than I develop it developing
developing pliers let's make a try bye
so Blake Griffin but A's the face of
your franchise and soon he could be the
face of yours right but who would you
want for him the bias is a good
developing player yes him all right you
got yourself a deal if we Bradley boban
the Giant and a first-round pick I mean
that's quite a lot what kind of contract
you got them under five years 171
million 700 thoughts all of gold I mean
sir Griffin's a marvelous talent and all
do you know he once dunked over a horse
Clydesdale wow that's
I just hundred and seventy 1 million
gold it's a low and did you know he's
funny oh you know Blake tell us one of
your jokes home sure yeah
so cheers thanks for coming out everyone
so my Squire year some of the older
blokes take me to a whorehouse that one
not that one
right um so a ref walks into a bar and
then a table and then some chairs Oh
Missy's cuz that F is blind that's great
Lonnie huh it's a deal
[Music]
ferdi weld house pistons and remember
stay away from those analytics folks
[Music]
were they doing not there if the
ceremonial exodus to the van Gandhi's
please keep our tidings to the maiden
Rihanna I don't think she's a maiden is
a lot I've got a feeling we're gonna
have a long but I'd future together
Blake
[Music]
you